pour les entreprises c'est la dernière
ligne droite la mise en place de l'euro
a lieu maintenant dans quatre mois pour
ce qui concerne les échanges en monnaie
sonnante et trébuchante dans de nombreux
secteurs on active la formation des
salariés comme c'est le cas chez relay
cette enseigne spécialisée dans la vente
des journaux dans les gares et les
aéroports reportage florence griffon et
patrice brugère pour passer dès fois
l'heure où il suffit de multiplier par
le taux aurait il faut
et ce n'est surtout pas le moment de se
tromper ces élèves d'un jour gère de
bureau de tabac le 1er janvier prochain
les clients paieront en francs ils
devront rembourser en euros pour que
tout se passe bien la direction du
groupe a préféré anticiper
ils font nos clients nous demandent des
services rapides ils nous demandent
également un professionnalisme et sa
passe également par le service encaisse
donc il nous faut être performant dès le
premier jour pour le moment les vendeurs
s'habitue au double étiquetage en
attendant les double quai ici comme dans
de nombreux commerces on compte aussi
sur la bonne volonté des consommateurs
pour se mettre à l'euro pour cette
cliente cela va de soi
internet palmarolle du commerçant de
m'informer je pense que c'est plutôt le
rôle des médias lourds des banques en
priorité et le forez ressemble je pense
qu'il faut qu'il reste toujours aimable
vous avez des contacts par on ne sait
pas pour moi le commerçant la part belle
à l'informatique 100 francs - 4 france 5
ans
et de lui rendre 14 euros 55 mais pour
eric c'est tellement peu évident qu
après les cours il vise en famille avec
ce jeu il espère bien connaître l'euro
sur le bout des doigts ce qui ne dissipe
pas ses inquiétudes
dans les magasins ça rizet les
encaissements risque d'être plus long
parce que soit le vendeur ou la vendeuse
ou le gérant connais pas très bien ce
amener le client là connaisseurs encore
moins que nous donc on va faire preuve
de solidarité dans les coups durs
heureusement pour tout le monde les
caisses enregistreuses
fonctionneront à plein régime je
voudrais loup - n'ont pas d'état d'âme
50 euros